I told you about our fields I told you
about our failed heist the one that led
the iron wheel to Abbas landing someone
pointed them in our direction it's time
we found out exactly who it was my gold
is unveil sir she was part of our
thieves Council the guilds inner circle
but she retired just before the dowry
heist it might be coincidence or it
might be she sold us out for large
stacks of coin that's what I'd like to
find out you and I should pay her a
visit see if the iron wheel funds her
retirement there's a breach in the city
wall outside the flooded district meet
me there when you're ready
these should always
and care to earn a little extra coin on
the side it's for a good cause over here
you
keeping myself busy
wait email and P white
traps everywhere you can't fall asleep
the iron you hear are they protecting
balsa
what's this message to Chief Inspector
run Beach let's see what it says damn it
damn it change of plans
you need to see this this message is to
Chief Inspector run beak it's about an
arrest order else's arrest order she
isn't working with the iron wheel she's
their next target Elsa was the last
living person who could have placed the
iron wheel on our trail but it wasn't
her of course it wasn't now I need to
tell my least-favorite person that she's
in mortal danger I can't stand her but
she was always one of our best I could
really use her help in restoring the
Thieves Guild I just wished I need to
control that around Elsa never show her
you tell I want a Russian give the iron
wheel a reason to fear us but I'm in
charge and if I'm captured the Thieves
Guild is dead I believe I'm saying this
but I need to fall back to the den while
you warned Elsa show her the iron wheels
message until her Nicholas is dead if
you have to do what you can to bring her
to the den but if she refused nothing
the upper levels and search for her
villa it's a bit of a maze but look for
a big garden and watch for traps elsa is
enthusiastic about her privacy
did you fall the land directly upon your
skull I am tired
you made it past my traps
you're lucky stupid or quite skilled I
haven't decided which well my god needs
tending out with it and be on your way
what thieves guild the iron wheel killed
or branded a lot of them did your
illustrious guild master syndrome tell
Nikolas if he shows his face here I'd
have a mind to slap it with a switch
covered in Nettles
they went through with this damned fool
heist so guild master zerah sends a
warning does she
Nikolas barely in the ground and she
seeks to approve my retirement the old
cistern zerah wouldn't warn me unless
she wanted something and i would like to
see the quality of recruits she allows
him to her thieves dim very well help me
repay a favor and I'll play zeros vastly
inferior game this is where you agree ah
you showed interest I'll consider that
your agreement the skittish Khajiit
pretending not to ease drop his silver
claw ask him why he needs our help meet
me behind his old warehouse after you
know what you're walking into
the Thieves Guild restored to Abbas
landing I am most grateful for your
timely and unexpected assistance you see
my bountiful warehouse was taken from me
by some conniving and nefarious
individual that is the question I keep
asking myself one day I arrived to find
unfamiliar guards they chased me from my
own warehouse like a common dragon frog
someone must have bribed my overseers it
does not matter I need you to recover
what was lost
what know did I fail to mention the
ledger hidden in my old office I may
have lost my warehouse but the ledger is
worth twice that entire rickety building
if you help well sir restore it to me I
shall be most grateful to the Thieves
Guild then I shall look forward to our
next most auspicious meeting
[Music]
you're here and relatively unskilled
next is this significantly harder part
first we sneak into the warehouse next
we observe our surroundings part you do
exactly what I tell you to do good you
can take direction did he tell you it's
packed with dirt on merchants throughout
Abbas landing how would you react when I
bring her a grateful silver claw in his
insidious ledger I do hope it makes her
eye twitch follow me and keep quiet fool
brain I meant guild master zerah
but yes we'll need to get past that
overseer to reach silver claws old
office first you'll wait for me to get
into position then you'll distract him
so I can knock him on the head here take
the sting cable the fool
I meant now chemically infused apple
throw it hard enough and it breaks open
surrounding your enemy with a rancid
bouquet or boiled next parts try not to
miss make your way past the guards
silver clock hit the ledger in his old
office we meet there now wait until I'm
in position then throw the stink apple
lift with your legs not your back you
fool
guards on their way get out the guard
will be here any second live summon the
God your chance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
the guard right away let's get out
before they clear you out
[Music]
through the Apple was too complex for
you this way
someone's coming
hide before we see you
I left a surprise in the house but it's
not ready not yet
you see no one here trying to cover up
for your nap talking is ever vigilant
there's an intruder in this warehouse
kasia's people are on their way to
inspect the warehouse we don't have time
for this nonsense
explosion talk being knew something was
amiss surprise you fools
I'll collect silver claw meet us back at
the thieves den
an explosion wrong to the nearest tavern
the guard knows how to deal with the
likes of you
you have the ledger to restore my
fortunes from my humble shop it is near
the docks you can't miss it well you can
easily miss it it is hard to find but
you are always welcome
I guess you took the long way don't rush
me
the overseer mentioned someone coming to
expect the warehouse gosh was it must be
a new player I hadn't heard the name
before I retired it always comes to coin
with you bars Landing merchants Lords
consolidate the competition locked them
in a set of gilded chains then profit
but not that warehouse my distraction
made it undesirable my own concoction
been poured into a crate filled with
sawdust the crate emits a thick smoke
any reasonable person would reach for a
bucket of water to douse what appears to
be oncoming flame yet it reacts quite
pour the deafening bang is the least of
it the smoke increases tenfold making
the mating orders of a female dragon
frog every minute and fraud in the city
should fill the warehouse by Sunrise
hope they confuse cautious shoes for a
mate
you
back without Belson